I only have four minutes but [ __ ] it I'm
gonna bring up hans zimmer so i'm so do
I get a forever so I'm always gonna get
approved for one-on-ones now surely
because I introduced you to Hans Zimmer
yes that's how it works right I'm out
yeah I don't need anything else today no
I think you've got an infinite number of
one-on-ones later to get whatever
questions you want um you know it's
funny it's you never as an outsider
because I'm just a movie fan you never
get to see that first interaction of
like two extremely talented artists like
meeting for the first time who like
clearly admire each other's work you
know uh well thank you for making that
uh making that happen fun a fun Toronto
Film Festival moment um yeah now let me
jump into your spectacular film um I
really specifically want to talk about
filming the moon sequence in IMAX it is
jaw-dropping talk a little about the
challenges of actually pulling this off
because I'm not mistaken you guys have
to create like a light that has never
been used or something crazy well you
know a credit to Lena Sangren my
brilliant scimitar gopher who's also a
little crazy and decided that well the
best way to shoot this would be to shoot
it outside at night and basically
simulate the Sun with a giant film
lights biggest film light anyone has
ever used and so we shot it at a rock we
found this rock quarry outside Atlanta
which Nathan Crowley our production
designer his entire team sculpted into
the lunar surface basically and so we
spent several nights there shooting the
light burned out a few times
but it worked at the end of the day it
snowed one of the nights I remember
which you know it's not exactly what we
wanted to happen but you know with all
the stops and starts we still managed to
get something I think pretty pretty cool
in the camera there one of the things
that I think is really cool is that
when you're on that moon mission it
never cuts back to NASA you're with the
astronauts and normally like you in a
movie you always cut back to that
feel-good moment you know the eagle has
landed and you see NASA just cheering
yeah so what was did you ever get studio
notes or ever debate of cutting back or
did you always know you wanted to
sort of stay with them we always knew he
wanted to stay with them I mean it felt
like it felt like that was one way to I
guess stay true to what we wanted to do
with the movie as a whole which was to
be subjective to really see what Neil
saw to hear what he heard and to to kind
of immerse the audience in this
experience I wanted the audience to feel
like they themselves went into space
that they went to the moon of course
cutting back I think would have ruined
the illusion of that experience it would
have sort of undercut it so it felt like
we had to kind of go all the way with
this and not return to Earth until Neil
does I would imagine that listen what
was it about this and I know you think
you were working on this before in la-la
land
or well III had written lala land and
tried to get lala land off the ground
for a while but I first started working
on this before we shot a lot of land but
what was it about this story and this
material that compelled you and said I
want to spend a few years of my life
working on this I think it was just
realizing how little I knew about
something that I thought I knew about
it's such a famous event neil is such a
famous individual but just starting to
read Jim's book Jim Hansen's book that
the movies based on
Minoo I was just amazed right away by
you know learning how dangerous this
whole enterprise was how how close to
failure who this this this these
missions leading up to and including
Apollo 11 were the the sacrifices that
Neil and Janet and their whole family
had to make I think I just it just
opened my eyes it made me realize that
there was a there was a version of this
story that we could tell that would be
fresh that was not sugar-coated that
would that would kind of strip away the
mythology a little bit and look at the
real reality that I think is even more
heroic and you know and and maybe as we
were talking about take the audience
themselves on the ride make them feel
like they were going into space with
these individuals
yeah I was gonna say the only thing you
did wrong with not give them capes capes
yes because they were all heroes you you
you you you would have done the capes
maybe not me personally but it could
have been done it could have been done
cooking oh well there's still time you
know movie comes out in a few weeks we
can really keep this in mind oh no
seriously it's it's really
[Music]
[Music]